Ron DeSantis and other Republicans don't
want this next election or really
anything to be about foreign policy it's
their Achilles heel they don't know
anything about it they don't care the
base they have to deal with
um is actively hostile to any discussion
of foreign policy and adopted a kind of
sour no-nothingism about foreign policy
and those are the primary voters it's
the very core of the GOP base those are
the primary voters that they have to get
past and those voters don't want to hear
anything about foreign policy or NATO or
Ukraine or zielinski because they watch
a lot of TV they don't know much more
else does that clown understand that
he's on TV in a box with five other
know-nothings the smugness of this guy
Tom Nichols that these people don't care
about foreign policy